Speaker 1: Guys, I love this story. Mike
Pillow, Mike Lindell, the CEO of MyPillow.
He was just finishing up, giving a speech in
Colorado, and he was served with a lawsuit
on camera. This is. I love this. I relish
this. Is it schadenfreude? Schadenfreude?
Every time I say it, someone emailed me,
says David. You're pronouncing it wrong.
You guys know exactly what I'm talking about as
Mike Pillow is walking away from a speech about
election integrity in Colorado. He gets served
by Eric Koumas. Defamation lawsuit Eric Coomer is
this former employee of Dominion Voting Systems.
Pillow has been hammering on Coomer for a while,
and the best part about this video is initially,
Pillow doesn't realize he's being served legally
here, and he tries to kind of walk away and says
he doesn't want the papers. Then he realizes he's
been served and he looks dejected and he sounds
dejected. And I love it. I really do. Take a look
at this video. Listen to the audio here.
Speaker 3:
Thank you, Mike. Thank you for everything.
What is this? Oh, sure, sure. What does this tell
you? Well, what is enough for me? It's not for me.
I need you to open up my bathroom. Oh dear, sorry.
Speaker 1: To informed.
It's always nice to have video evidence
of proof of service. Sue, all these guys,
if the facts point that way. Sue every single
one of them and it's I don't know if this
is even a guilty pleasure of mine, but you
really love to see it. And I don't know that
Mike Pillow realizes the amount of trouble
that he's in. This really could destroy him
financially. He has a lot of money. I know it
really could. Sidney Powell, the other she was,
I guess she's she still is a lawyer, even
though she's been disbarred a bunch of places.
She was pushing a lot of these bogus, frivolous
legal complaints around the 2020 election.
I'm you never hear me say sue them. I say sue
them if the evidence points to it. And it seems
that the evidence points to lawsuits against Mike
Pillow and one of the things that again, we talk
about projection the right. Generally speaking,
it's the right that says we need tort reform,
which often by tort the tort reform, they mean
we need to make it more difficult for individuals
to be able to hold corporations accountable. You
have to understand in general when they when the
right talks about tort reform, they mean let's
make it easier for corporations to do whatever the
hell they want and make it more difficult for them
to be held accountable. They talk all the time
about frivolous lawsuits, frivolous. So this
lawsuits frivolous. That lawsuit is frivolous.
Courts can determine that courts
have courts are very well-equipped,
equipped to determine whether a lawsuit should
or shouldn't move forward. And if it shouldn't,
they dismiss lawsuits? And one of the things
that was found by courts is that they were
filing the frivolous lawsuits and frivolous
legal complaints in the aftermath of the 2020
election. And if they've done it in a way that
is systematic and is a waste of the court's time,
100 percent hold them accountable pillows getting
sued again, and he's got a big legal bill coming
and something about that. VIDEO That video
is from a Marshall Selinger with nine news.
Really good job of Salinger was just
there, and he happened to get the process
server delivering the papers. It's just fantastic.
He has got a big uphill legal battle in front of
him. And of course, he continues to claim
pillow. Does that were like days from the
evidence coming out or whatever? It's wacky.
These people are bonkers. And unfortunately,
a lot of their followers believe every word
they say. So we'll track this lawsuit. But you
really love to see that clip if you didn't. If
you're listening today and you're not watching,
you can see the delivery of the papers. We'll
have it on our Instagram at David Pakman show.